a lot of us are planning vacations and
getaways but there are some things to
keep in mind before you head out and
triple a smart home the sponsors of
today's segment are here to help joining
us is john traynor how are you it's good
to see you i know we go way back we go
way back but now we get to talk about
some really important stuff here so all
of us you know we're getting ready we're
packing our bags maybe gonna head out on
a road trip or take a vacation but what
are some things that we should really
keep in mind before we go on vacation
the first thing you do when it hits 100
degrees is you plan to leave las vegas
that's what we should all do for at
least a little bit a respite over the
summer
it's been a long time since we've done
that it's been the pandemic you may not
have left for a long time so you got to
think about what you should do you might
forget some stuff
you might forget hey those garage doors
you might forget to tell people you're
leaving you might just have anxiety
about not being in your house right what
we recommend is kind of going through
that checklist in your mind did i alert
my friends and family i'm gone did i
make sure the thermostat was off those
kind of small things that you don't
really think about what smart home can
do is all that stuff while you're on the
road well i love it and these are really
important whether you're on the road or
not but especially you know they say
that people check their phones and
everything even more so when they're
gone to make sure everything is safe at
home so what are some of these gadgets
that you have in front of us that really
could be a lifesaver right okay so about
a third of us have a smart doorbell you
know one of those ones that has the
camera on there smart home is that it
has that as well along with keyless
entry so you get alerted that a package
got delivered and you're not home
somebody can come put that package in
your door so people aren't alerted to
the fact that you're not home because a
package has been sitting there
we have inside security cameras smoke
alarms that are hooked up to the rest of
the smoke alarms in your house we have
motion sensors glass break sensors door
sensors in case someone opens your door
window where you're gone it all operates
out of a smart control panel and of
course you're always looking at your
phone notification so everything gets
routed to your phone so you can control
everything from your phone which is
really helpful and you know we do it all
the time did i leave this on did i leave
that is the garage open so now you guys
make it really easy wherever you are
traveling you can always look back and
make sure everything is all good at home
and when it comes especially to the
thermostat i'm always really interested
in this because you never know should i
turn it off when i'm gone should i keep
it on does this help regulate and keep
things kind of smooth sailing that's the
idea if you're not in town to hear
jerry's forecast and you're away you
might have forgotten well maybe the air
conditioner is going a little too much
or the heat's going a little too much
this can help you regulate it from away
and it can lower your energy bill 16 to
23 percent while you do it the garage
door you mentioned where you can control
that as well in case you did leave it
open and the sensors are great because
you don't want to have that notification
someone's trying to break in my house
the glass broke you left a window open
in the back you left the door open all
of that gets alerted to your phone so
you can call someone if you need help or
we can do that for you absolutely yeah
and if people are watching at home and
they want to get their hands on some of
this what's the best way for them to
reach out to you guys aaa smart home
website is the best way to do it we have
packages where you can monitor it all
yourself or we can monitor it for you so
if someone alerts that your door got
open or your window got broken
aaa will make the phone call for you you
can call 9-1-1 you can call the
authorities if you have elderly family
members at home you have panic buttons
so it's great maybe health conscious
people or somebody who has a medical
issue you hit that button help is on the
way well john thank you so much this is
all really helpful also happy belated
father's day very sad now so great to
see you thank you thank you for breaking
all this down and thank you again to
triple a smart home for sponsoring this
segment for more information call
800-669-7779
or visit aaa.com
smart home they also have that special
offer for you from now until july 31st
aaa smart home is offering free
professional installation 199 value jc i
will send it over to you thank